[Music]
in sad hero cop news submitted by three
three finger [ __ ]
three finger [ __ ] hey don't smoke here
go smoke over there one of the first
responding officers from the pulse
nightclub shooting is now losing his job
you mean that Florida terrorists shoot
shoot at the gay nightclub right yeah
yeah back in June 2016
what did the police happen to do here
[Music]
man your English is awesome but you
understand what I said right Oh perfect
time perfect perfect timing picture oh
my god oh he works for the eatonville
Police Department looks like he's part
of a calendar shoot like February he's a
model and there was definitely about 40
photos before they chose that one yeah
why cuz it looks like it was just too
perfect no you can tell yeah you're good
sighs when you're odd because your
eyeballs are slightly bigger right
and it's supposed to be a good sides the
one where your eyeball I didn't know
that that's what Nicky told me well
she's a big believer in good side bad
side like it's all [ __ ] rekt so
[ __ ] know the side you just pick the
[ __ ] that looks less vulgar yeah let's
do it
yeah that's all good god damn a buck and
ass it's pretty bad that's [ __ ] I'm like
in a piece is a swear word yeah God bang
alright so what about mr. February
there's one of the first responders he
was held a hero because he helped one of
the victims this guy angel is like a
baby yeah alright I'm here [ __ ]
arrest you
so he was one of the victims of the
shooting right so he was saying that
thanks to this cop he now lives because
when he found him when the count when
the cop found the victim he's I know
sorry
was because in my mind every word you're
saying creates an image when you said
cow I went from cop to cow real quick so
when the cop arrived they're saying that
angel he was bleeding so much he was so
injured like he probably would have died
if it wasn't for this cop he took on to
get treatment or so he was held a hero
so now he's in the news because the city
has decided to let him go and so now it
it seems like it's it's a financial
reason so Omar Omar has been working at
at the police department for nine and a
half years in just six more months he
will be able to get into the pension
system and he'll be able to collect
sixty four percent of his 38 thousand
five hundred dollars salary and benefits
for life if you make it up to the ten
years that's why they fired at this town
is financially struggling they're saying
that this is the nation's oldest
incorporated african-american town and
how many text money
it has about 2,000 people and a really
small Police Department which is where
he works and so it seemed like from my
own speculation it seems like they're
letting him go because they probably
can't afford that
well the fire of the non hero cop there
you go where he's about to reach that
pension right maybe they just don't like
the hero cop they're like man that's
that I don't like him better I've always
wanted that like like it's always like
whenever you hear somebody got killed
right you always hear like oh he was
such a great guy but like haven't
[ __ ] died too that's what I'm saying
like why don't the neighbors like why
did the neighbors ever like oh that guy
was a [ __ ] dick I mean ya know he
died and know that though right like oh
thank god brutal obituary we did a JK
news about them their family they wrote
a obituary about their father who was a
[ __ ] and then
you know like a bully great all that
he's like this is who he really was the
daughter watched the the video and then
sent us a book this is the recent cuz
you only ever hear the real [ __ ] if the
guy was a murderer then they're always
like he was such an [ __ ] like oh yeah
he used to get his mail in a weird way
for like you know what's something weird
like oh he was very quiet I always
thought that was a little weird but then
I mean if it's somebody else they're
like oh he was the best yeah I want to
see someone go on news is like a hundred
percent I was warning everyone I told
everyone that food
he just looks creepy right like he was
just bound if I can snap and kill
everybody is I just look at him let's
put a picture up just look at this guy
yeah maybe they have you on it I mean
I'd love that yeah I want to see it I
feel bad for this guy though a lot of
cops they join because of the pension
cuz it's hella good and then like six
months from getting it they fire them so
always gonna do now the department won't
state exactly why they're letting him go
they're saying that it's a confidential
thing and they're also saying that the
department reached an agreement with
Omar and his employment and so as of
right now as it stands he will only
receive 42% of a salary starting when
he's 55 which is in 10 years because
he's 45 now so he still has to work so
instead of getting sixty four percent of
his salary he'll be getting forty two
percent but not until ten years from now
Oh
so almost saying that one of the reasons
he speculates as to why they're letting
him go is because he suffers from PTSD
so after the whole Orlando shooting he
he ended up he went back out on the
streets to patrol but then after a
couple months like he just couldn't do
it anymore because his PTSD so he ended
up taking a desk job so he's been doing
yeah you got to put you at the desk okay
you saw some [ __ ] out there I'm putting
you behind a desk no you can't do it to
me man the streets yeah put me back out
there yeah but then every time he passes
like a club and he hears his dick he
can't go to restaurants or bars cuz
there's just too many people he says
like he can't he's like I can't hear ETM
yeah no EBM no money ATM no gay
festivals I see two guys kissing each
other I flip out not for the reason you
think I pull my gun out no no because I
was in a nightclub during a shooting
they were making caps going through
there people make it out with each other
no it makes sense because it's like we
might not live forever honey kiss me you
know like in the movies they do that all
the time stop okay stop [ __ ] Omar
he's just saying like he he helped that
he would have more support from the
department especially like he he
believes that there should be more
support for first responders suffering
from PTSD so right now there's a bill
that has advanced and the bill is
requiring coverage for mental health
treatment in work compensation insurance
for first responders with PTSD so it
would call for funding for PTSD
treatment if there was if it resulted
from witnessing a murder/suicide fatal
injury child death or arriving at a mass
casualty situation and so the treatment
under this bill the treatment would
begin within 15 days of the injury and
so it would be through a certified
licensed psychiatrist and so that's what
the bill is
right now so they don't have like
treatment programs for officers that
witness crazy [ __ ] I mean I didn't look
into that but I think it's by Department
because I I'm sure LAPD yeah I mean like
my brother has PTSD cuz he was in the
Air Force and he saw some [ __ ] and he
just got cleared for like a medical
thing that gives him like a certain
amount money for the rest of his life
Wow other cop who was also in Buehrle
and he was involved in the whole [ __ ]
crazy I swear there's nothing you don't
do this flight suit everyone she
targeted him like he's a nanny it's a
specific flies there is this one
specific flag he's bugging all of us
anyway so they do mention this article
this other officer that the Orlando
Police Department did grant an early
retirement
back in July to this officer who's 37
years old he was diagnosed with PTSD he
will get about 80% of his $70,000 for
life that's like 50 56 G's in here for
life we get PTSD people can come into a
lot of different shapes and sizes I
think you got your ass beat you probably
have it as small straight up dude
whenever somebody raises their hand in
class I put there you go just like
granted dude there are some girls that I
had sex with that gave me PTSD hundred
percent the lights were just too on this
is too much light
why didn't you stop it before when it's
the better I couldn't stop it once you
start you can't stop
yeah it's you know I I wanted to stop
believe me but it now I we just couldn't
say no couldn't say no like it's our
crying right now if you really want to
what's going on with all the way here
like he just he's getting fired wouldn't
left like out in the cold and I just
pictured him walking around sad like
tumbleweed yeah
hands in the pocket is [ __ ] like nothing
a bucket so there's the other Turner's
gun and badging like in the movies too
like you do have to do that
yeah that's time dude I hope he doesn't
go homeless cuz he's gonna be like one
of those dudes that I see in the street
that I think it's a [ __ ] liar like I
used to be a cop I used to be a [ __ ]
dude why do you smell urine over and
over or not dude military guys get
treated like [ __ ]
I believe everybody who's homeless who
says they were veterans hotter percent
oh man oh yeah the VA was just has been
such a nightmare for these guys I
remember there was this one bomb that me
and Bart we were driving and then he
asked Bart for money was like oh you're
military cuz he saw his like Chevron's
or something on the car and then he was
like yeah spend your money wisely like
you said it to him like I [ __ ] up I
was doing a video a couple years ago
where I got a homeless guy I picked him
up from the street and I got a like gave
him the best day of his life cuz all
these YouTube prankster guys were
picking up homeless guys and they were
like taking him and buying t-shirts and
buying them hot meals and [ __ ] and like
just filming themselves doing charity
work and acting like they're great
people
yeah so I got this guy and I picked him
up from the street he was a real
homeless guy and I took him to a to a
dinner and I bought him dinner and I was
like we're filming all this [ __ ] right
like we're filming all this [ __ ] and he
knew what was going on
because I was making fun of these
YouTube prankster guys yeah but by the
end of the night I got him a hotel room
I filled it entirely with balloons and I
had a sign that says Steve green
greatest person to guys in the world and
I'm like and I had a theme song playing
when he walked in the room is like Steve
green man he's so awesome he like keeps
so charitable and awesome and and then
this guy like he's taking like the
brothers balloons all over the bed so
he's pulling the bedspread off like
there's balloons everywhere like he's
trying to get him off the bed because
it's just balloons everywhere filling
the whole room with balloons
inconvenient amount of balloons Wow but
what was great is at the end of the day
I was like hey man obviously like you
can keep this hotel room like thanks for
your help with the video cuz he'll agree
with my message he thought all these
guys doing this stuff cuz he had a ball
he could watch these YouTube videos and
he's seen people taking advantage of
homeless people filling them so Larry
what the hell they walk away with them
both a million bucks exactly exactly and
so he was down with it but at the end
the day I was like given you could stay
here for the night like I have it for
the whole night and he was like honestly
dude like can you just take me back to
my hotel cuz he's like it's like I do
pretty well flying assign leave he's
like I make like I made like 200 bucks a
day I doing the [ __ ] I was like okay
like like you know yeah and I was trying
to I was thinking like hey you would
like this and then he's like no no no
maybe if the Ritz pal yeah this is motel
6 take me back to the sheriff she spit
in your face yeah yeah so you can keep
the rental car he's like I don't drive
Ford man picked him up on the street he
just walked up to any old guy he was
flying a sign and I walked up to him and
I was like hey man I would like to give
you like like a like a hundred bucks and
you just hang out with me for the day
and I was like I'll give you a hundred
I'll give you a hundred on or whatever
and then he's like yeah absolutely I'd
love to and so this is have to work
that's it yeah and then I explained it
to him cuz I cuz I basically am addicted
him the whole video because I'm but it's
really not about me being a dick to him
it's about me making fun of these
prankster people so I was happy to let
him in on that joke because I'm not
making fun of him did you put this video
yeah yeah it's called like homeless guy
life changed forever like touching story
must see my faster [ __ ] [ __ ] hate
them
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]